housekeeping announcements uh before we
begin
as i've stated earlier at this time if
you could please add your name and
affiliation to the um screen for
yourself the way you do that is to hover
over your image
three dots will appear
and from there if you move down to
rename you can then add whatever text
you'd like
above your image so again please add
your name and affiliation
if you have any problems please use the
chat feature and we will assist you
if any of you will be using slides as
presenters please use the screen share
function on zoom to do so
and after each agenda item there'll be
time for questions
we ask that you please use the q a
feature in zoom
to submit your questions
it looks like we have uh
participants still joining so perhaps
we'll give it one or two minutes more
before we start the event
all right good morning i'm just going to
repeat some housekeeping items here
before we begin the actual event
uh please those of you who have just
joined and haven't already done so
please add your name and affiliation
you will do so by hovering over your
image finding the three dots clicking on
those three dots and then going down to
rename and from there you can type in
any information
that you'd like
during today's event if you have any
problems please use the chat feature and
we the staff at the institute will
assist you
for those of you that will be making
presentations please use the zoom
screen share feature to do so
after each agenda item there'll be time
for questions
please use the q a feature on zoom to
submit those questions
so welcome to the simon's institute's
quantum industry day 2021
my name is william humnicky i'm the
director of operations and planning here
uh i would like you to
please note uh that during the event
today
i will be timekeeper so when there is
five minutes remaining in each segment i
will be speaking up to notify you that
that is the case and again at the end of
each segment i will notify that time's
up
it'll be up to our scientific leadership
to decide if they want to extend at that
point
and please note that this event is being
recorded
so i'd now like to turn over the event
to shafi goldwasser the dirac director
i'm sorry of the simon's institute and
umesh bazarani research director for
quantum commuting at the simons
institute
please shafi
hi everyone and good morning eastern
california it's uh good morning um so
i'd like to welcome you to the quantum
industry day which is the first of its
kind we have industry days every year
but this we have a special day which is
just dedicated to quantum computing
um so i'm the director i've been a
director for the last
coming of four years i wanted to share a
little bit of information with you about
the institute for those of you who are
new uh to our institute and then i will
uh pass to umesh vazirani who's our
research director for quantum computing
and he'll tell you all about this
particular day and about quantum
computing at
the simons institute so i'm going to
share my slides now i hope i have a few
slides
and i'd like to show them to you
eh here they go
can you see them
i hope you can all right so um
the simon's institute was funded founded
uh about almost 10 years ago so it's
going to be a 10-year anniversary this
summer and it was due to a very generous
grant from the simon's foundation and
the mission
is
very explicitly dedicated from the
beginning to explore computation the
nature computation and the limits of
computation and expand uh the foundation
of computing the mathematics behind
computation through collaborative
research programs and when we say
foundations of computing we really don't
just mean in some abstract sense but as
it touches many other fields not only
mathematics but natural and social
sciences which in very relevant today
through physics
biology
economics um we have programs that touch
with engineering technology directly
a lot of activity as
in the foundations of cryptography
security privacy and a lot of activity
in machine learning and data science in
the last few years
uh we are the only research institute in
the world that's dedicated to the
mathematical foundation of computing so
there are research institutes
dedicated to mathematics
they must arrive up the hill uh for
example in physics but um
really if you look at the angle of
computation and the mathematics
complication we are very unique this way
and uh part of the reason that um i
think that jim simons believed and we
believe that this is um
very important to do this research with
this particular focus is that there's
been a huge impact on basic ideas
theoretical ideas in computer science
um
in the world around us you know whether
it's electronic commerce or cloud
computing or search
uh cryptocurrencies these days or
quantum computing um
it really is very easy to trace the idea
to some basic theoretical question that
was studied and an idea that was
invented and made its way to practice
uh we are a collaborative research
center which means that the way we um
operate is through
convening researchers together
we have several structures for convening
one of them which is sort of the pillar
is the semester-long research programs
um of which we have two each semester so
four year
and the participants are leaders from
around the world rising stars and senior
people and usually we have a boot camp
and then three workshops which are
dedicated to specific topics we have
weekly seminar series reading groups you
know graduate courses distinguished
lecture
lectures and so forth and uh mesh will
tell you what we're doing um
with respect to quantum what we've done
in the past as well
uh we have summer clusters so these are
shorter programs bring less people
together to study more focus topics
and then our new vehicles research pods
where we have something that's beyond
the summer beyond semester lasts for two
three years maybe more and it's a group
of senior researchers and postdocs or
junior researchers containing sustained
research in an area
and every once in a while it's
punctuated by
research programs and clusters where we
bring more people in
and one of these research problems again
is that going to be dedicated to quantum
and we have it right now and um which
will speak about that i just want to say
that it's a pity that you can't come and
visit us in simons
because we have or we've decided at
least that it will be the best mechanism
today to do this online we have a
fabulous space
on campus at berkeley which is a
beautiful campuses is and i believe that
our building is one of the most
beautiful ones with a lot of um common
spaces for interaction white boards um
and various kind of um convening spaces
so we hope that in the future we'll see
more of you in person
uh just to finish what we're doing more
generally this semester we have two
programs going on and we have many many
postdocs so i just have a few more
slides to punctuate sort of what we're
doing this semester so first of all we
have an expanded postdoctoral program i
know that a lot of the our industry uh
affiliates and partners are interested
in this of the younger generation coming
through the pipeline so we will really
have a very large cohort of postdocs
about 54 of them
uh some of them are associated with a
particular research program
about eight per program
but we have also post doctoral
researches that are associated directly
with the quantum part we have um
also a
machine learning part and there are
postdoctoral researchers associated with
them and
then more general simons berkeley
post-doctoral researchers who are
mentored by faculty members in berkeley
and all together it's going to be about
54 postdocs in the la in the next
over this year and next year
and they are some of them are associated
with nsf funding from darpa funding with
industrial partnerships and the simon's
foundation itself
the programs um
often um the people who come to the
programs uh sometimes we name them as
fellows named uh
in association with our industrial
um
sponsors and here are some associations
with the industrial sponsors and the
postdocs who are named fellows
um
and finally
we have two programs this semester one
of them is the computational complexity
of statistical inference
uh the organizers are as you see are
from around the world some from mit from
ut austin
um from
uh elsewhere uh around the globe
stanford and from berkeley
uh yale uh and we've already had the
boot camp we've had
a fascinating workshop a week ago and
there are two more to come and here the
whole question issue is now with the
emergence of statistics as a major
vehicle for discovery can we start
talking about
the complexity of samples in the same
way that computer science has
been known to study time and space
complexity
another program is geometrical methods
in optimization and sampling which is
highly related actually with the first
program i mentioned again we have
leaders from around the world including
berkeley again we've had the boot camp
and we
are going to have three more workshops
coming up
and now i
want to turn over
the baton to the really uh man of the
hour which is
iranian he's the research director for
quantum computing and he'll tell you
uh
you know the rest of the story so mish
do you want me to switch the slides uh
no yeah let me let me share my myself
i'm gonna show you one okay so i will i
will get out of sharing mode
um
if i manage to do so let's see
so i think i stopped sharing
okay great uh yeah thanks a lot uh shafi
and um yeah welcome everybody to this
event um
as you know uh
um we are
at a
pretty unique point in in history it's a
it's a really exciting time in
in quantum computing right now
and um
you know we in in a sense um you know
our field suffers from an embarrassment
of riches both in terms of uh the
exciting questions the techniques you
know the energy as well as you know all
kinds of resources so at berkeley 2 we
have
we have our share of these these bridges
you know and so we have
these two new uh major institutes um
there's the nsf challenge institute for
quantum computing ciqc and the theory
quantum systems accelerator qsa
and uh actually um you know they they
they have together uh funded uh in
conjunction with uh some funding from
the science institute uh simon's
foundation for
this research part in in uh in quantum
computing at the science institute
now um
you know this this brings together
actually all these all these centers and
and the research board uh bring together
people from various areas physics
computer science
you know
experiment theory etc
and so we'll you know today we'll have
short presentations from each of these
uh but but also we have these two
uh fabulous panels so so what we're
hoping to do through this this event to
understand
where we stand in quantum computing
today you know what are the challenges
ahead and also there's a there's a lot
going on in both academia and industry
and federal labs and you know how do how
do we create a forum where we bring
everybody together to understand
both what the challenges are and how we
can you know help each other in this in
this process okay so let me
let me just say a little bit about uh
shafi already referred to this that um
at the same institute we had these uh
semester-long programs um so
we we had um such a one on quantum
computing in 2014 and then also last
year last spring uh
we had um we had a quantum computing
program that was that was co-located
with a with a program on lattices
um you know uh algorithms complexity
cryptography which as you can imagine
was was very closely tied you know there
were there were deep connections with
the quantum computing program and so
this co-location was extremely useful
in in terms of developing research
questions and directions
and and so
in a sense what this research board in
quantum computing does
is it takes this co-location idea to you
know sort of to the limit in the sense
that
what this does is it it it creates um
a group of post docs and senior visitors
who are here uh you know continuously
for for you know over the next several
years
and uh and they will they will get to of
course talk to each other and uh
you know and work on exciting questions
and talk to the campus community but
also they get to interact with the with
the
with the visitors at the program uh
programs which include uh
you know as we saw lattice cryptography
or machine learning algorithms
complexity theory and so it's really
quite a
remarkable uh you know environment
um
so um so in terms of uh you know
uh
so so we have uh you know we have a
large number of
really great postdocs who work on
um you know various aspects of of
quantum computing from algorithms to
complexity theory crypto uh you know
and
and
senior visitors um uh who who visit with
the visit the
the uh the res simons institute or for
some a semester or a year at a time
uh we've had a colloquium that we've
been running since uh since last since
the spring
which which was um designed to um
to deal with the with this issue that
you know at this point um
there's just uh you know various areas
are moving so quickly forward and it's
so hard to separate out what's important
and what's not and and to understand the
field and
where
even experts are having trouble keeping
up with things even slightly outside of
their narrow sub-area and so this
colloquium was designed to
to sort of make make some of these these
ideas more transparent and bring them to
to people and to do this we also added
uh tutorials but more importantly panel
discussions at the end of these these
colloquia and these have been incredibly
uh you know successful in the sense that
they bring a lot of people together
create a sense of community and also get
people up to date and you know in what's
what's going on
this summer we we actually uh decided
that um you know it was enough with uh
with virtual presence and and we
organized a summer cluster in quantum
quantum computing and uh
um
yeah it was um i i think it was it was
you know really nice for all the
participants to be together and working
in person and talking to each other and
brainstorming
um let me just very quickly because uh
and really nearly at the end of my time
let me just give you a sense of the
sorts of research themes that
that happen here so
uh
well you know a lot of the research
happens at the at the boundaries so for
example there's there's complexity
theory and quantum computing you know
quantum supremacy so how do you know
that that you actually achieved
quantum advantage
um so so there's there's a there's
ongoing and and recent work you know on
on
how do you know that um random circuit
sampling which was uh which was the
google experiment do we you know can we
sharpen the complexity theoretic uh
evidence that that really does uh solve
a problem that's not classically
solvable
or
there's more recent work on
you know whether whether the output of a
random the random circuit sampling
experiment is certifiably random
there's there's also a bit of a of a
of a revolution underway at this at this
intersection between cryptography and
quantum computing
um you know uh through the both through
the ideas about what else can you do in
terms of certified randomness uh you
know in a scalable way through through
cryptographic uh techniques but also
uh you know how you can make sure that
all the cryptography that's been built
up over the years
which parts of it remain secure under
under quantum
attack when you have post-quantum
cryptography
there's
a lot of work on simulation and quantum
anybody systems uh um you know both in
terms of structural properties and uh
and the performance of of this uh here
you know algorithm
uh rrg rigorously normalization group
and then there's work on quantum
benchmarking uh you know
how you can use random uh circuit
sampling to actually do
um uh benchmarking of uh the noise in
near-term computers in you know in some
somewhat provable ways okay so i'm going
to stop here because i think we are we
are out of time and we should really be
moving on to the panel which is i think
something that
that
all of us are looking forward to so
um okay so let me stop there and uh